E
ARE REALLY HAPPY AND PROUD OF
YOURSELVES.
GERALDO, THANK YOU,
CHARLIE HURT, THANK YOU.
ALSO TONIGHT, YET MORE
BEWILDERING BLUNDERS FROM, YES,
THE OFTEN GIGGLING
VICE PRESIDENT MOLLY HARRIS, WHO
WANTS TO LET US KNOW SHE REALLY
LIKES THE INTERNET.
I MEAN REALLY LIKES IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Vice President Harris:
CONTEXT THE INTERNET IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF LIFE IN THE
21ST CENTURY.
CAN'T GET AROUND IT.
CAN'T GET AROUND WITHOUT IT.
>> Sean: BIDEN, KAMALA, AND
NANCY PELOSI.
GOD HELP US.
ALL RIGHT.
DESPITE NOT YET COMPLETE IN ANY
OF HER OTHER JOBS, SECURING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, THE WHITE HOUSE
IS NOW GIVING THE VICE PRESIDENT
MORE RESPONSE ABILITIES.
NOW HEADING UP SOMETHING CALLED
AN ONLINE POLICY TASK FORCE,
WHATEVER THE HELL THAT MEANS.
YOU MIGHT BE WONDERING, WHAT
EXACTLY THAT TASK FORCE WILL DO.
WELCOME AT THIS POINT IT SEEMS
TO BE ANYBODY'S GUESS, EVEN
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
DOESN'T APPEAR TO KNOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
LEADING, GETTING KICKED OFF
TODAY, ON A BACKGROUND CALL LAST
NIGHT WE WERE TOLD IT'S GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT FROM THE
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE BOARD
AND THAT IT'S GOING TO FOCUS ON
ILLEGAL CONDUCT ONLINE, BUT THE
MEMO CREATING IT WAS OVER LITTLE
BIT BROADER AND MENTIONS,
QUOTING FROM A DOCUMENT, "ONLINE
HARASSMENT, ABUSE AND
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS
TARGETING WOMEN AND LGBTQ I PLUS
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PUBLIC AND
LYTIC FIGURES."
CAN YOU CLEAR UP THE
DISINFORMATION CHARGE?
I WOULD NEED TO TALK TO OUR
TEAM.
I WAS OUT OF THE BACK ON CALL,
SO THAT SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT
YOU'RE PROVIDING TO ME